بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
والعاقبه للمتقين ولا عدوان الا على
الظالمين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
تاكيدا بعد تاكيد لبي بيان مقام التوحيد
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
ان رياض الصالحين
المراقبه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الحافظ النووي
عمر بن الخطاب
حديث جبريل
عليه السلام
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الاسلام في اللغه
الان ايش الانقياد احسنت احسنت
الانقياد
وفي الشرع
ثلاثه اشياء صح
الاسلام هو
[Arabic recitation]
طيب
والانقياد له بالطاعه
والبراءه
من الشرك واهلهلام
‏submission
and
legislativ
in the language of the quر when you come
across the word islam
with respect toer
to
waser
يعني
افغير دين الاسلام يبغون
ويقول
افغير دين الله يبغون ويقول وله اسلم من
في السماوات والارض وله اسلم من في
السماوات والارض
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
شرعا الاسلام يعني ان الدين عند الله
الاسلام
هو سماك
المسلمين
ابراهيم عليه السلام
[Silence]
الاستسلام لله بالتوحيد
سبمشن الله توحيد والانقياد له بالطاعه
والبراءه من الشرك واهله
الايمان
ما معنى ايها العرب ما معنى الايمان لغه
ايمان
لage
ها
التصديق طيب ماشي حلو جميل معناه التصديق
طيب ايش الفرق بينه وبين التصديق
بدون رؤيه
ان الشي
[Arabic recitation]
دون رؤيه يعني لو لم يرى الشيء بنفسه قال
صدقت
لكن لو راى الشيء بنفسه قال امنت
راى الشيء
[Arabic recitation]
الايمان والتصديق
التصديق
الايمان
تصديق وليس ايمانا هكذا
فلسفه
‏I love
we getting close you know these words
when they chosen this way there's a
reason behind it right so think back
where this word is used right so for
instance
what
the children of او يعقوب عليه السلام
يوسف وما انت بمؤمن
لنا ولو كنا
صادقين
said you
don't know how
‏you afat
would you not believe and ate him
terrible right and but then they he
wasn't swallowing it he wasn't it he was
wol yes yes
then they want to get in deeper to his
heart they want him to just accept it
move on and they could happily ever
after because that's الشيطان
وتكونوا من بعده قوما صالحين
وما انت بمؤمن لنا ولو كنا صادقين
here
ايمان تصديق
‏wantine
تفسير
تقريبي
التفسير التقريب
تفسير
الايمان هو التصديق
لابري
هو الشك
والشك
الايمان والتصديق
الله سبحانه وتعالى الايمان
ايمان
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
قل اذن خير
لكم يؤمن بالله ويؤمن
للمؤمنين
لاحظوا اللام والباء يؤمن بالله
ويؤمن
للمؤمنين
هنا صارت صار كلمه الايمان تتعدى باللام
تتعدى بالباء ويختلف المعنى بتعدي باللام
والباء
صديق
الايمان
في اللغه
هو التصديق الجازم الذي لا يعت تريه شك
الايمان هو التصديق الجازم
الذي لا يتخلله شك
وهو
من شده التصديق يحمل على الانقياد يحمل
على العمل بمقتضى المؤمن به مفهوم هذا
الفرق بين الايمان والتص تصديق مثل النبا
والخبر ايش الفرق بين النبا والخبر النبا
الخبر لكن النبا لا يكون الا بالامور
العظيمه
لا يقال هذا نبا لشيء
تافه يقال هذا النبا لامر عظيم جلل يقتضي
القلق يقتضي ويحمل اصحابه
على القلق وعلى التفكر وعلى هذا هو النباص
‏Arab langage
that is so strong
that it is not
open to any
it has
in it that's first second
is when you say this
يؤمن بهul
whatever iseved
forces
notive
[Silence]
الايمان في اللغه هو التصديق الجازم
وله
بينه وبين التصديق فرقان الفرق الاول
يتخلله لا يعتريه الشك
الامر الثاني يحمل صاحبه على العمل بمقتضى
ما امن به
يحمل صاحبه على ايش؟ على العمل لما قالوا
ليعقوب وما انت بمؤمن لنا
وما انت بمؤمن لنا يعني شايفينك
شاك فينا وايضا
شايفينك
مش عام مش معاملنا معامله
اللي اللي مصدق التصديق الجازم لانه لو
كان التصديق الجازم كان يعقوب عليه السلام
بتشوف انه ما عنده شك وكان احتواهم
واحتضنهم وقال او مثلا انبهم ليش خليتوا
اخوكم ما ماشي لانه صدق انه الذئب لكن لما
جاؤوا بالق القصه هي وشك فيهم ما ما كان
عليهم ما انبهم ما قال لهم
الله اعلم الله اعلم تقولون هيك اكله
الذئب الله اعلم فصبر جميل
يعني سياتي الحق بعد حين
تصديق
‏lang
you something so strongly number one
there is no
number two it is something that affs
your action when you when you believe
something it affects your actions
because your actions now reflect that
belief that you are carry
رصق
الايمان
يؤمن بالله
‏Number two, the belief is so strong
that it affs the person's actions. And
that's why in the Quran iman is used to
refer to actions.
وما كان ليضيع
ايمانكم
يعني ايش صلاتكم
صلاتكم فعبر عن الصلاه بالايمان مع انه
الايمان عمل هنا
التصديق والايمان اوكي
لا ي الشك لا يتخلله الشك
والفارق الثاني ان الايمان ايش يؤثر في
العمل يحمل صاحبه على العمل بمقتضى
المؤمن به طيب
ايمان
ان قران سنه
‏compasy
[Silence]
يقولون الايمان
هو اعتقاد بالجنان
وقول باللسان
وعمل بالجوارح والاركان
يزيد بطاعه الرحمن
وينقص
بطاعه الشيطان
شو رايكم فيها هذه
كلها مسجوعه
ايزي
‏iefan
is whatever a person says with that is
also on the t
is also in a person action a person go
for we say this is this is part of right
it increases when you
‏And it decreases when you obean
or when you disobe Allah.
‏So element
of
the bodyes
and decreases you
person like
is a little low you get that like
my is a little what
يزيد بطاعه الرحمن
addise
will
not belief
ايمان
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ايمانر
ايمانه
allarate
and they are
what you believe and actions that you do
that are in line with that belief and
the statements that you make that are in
line with that belief
ر
اللهصلاه
سبحانه وتعالى
الايمان والتصديق
ايمان
[Silence]
صدقت
ابو ابو طالب
ابو طالب
صلى الله عليه
‏Yeah.
ايمان
صدق
[Silence]
لا الايمان
فيه نوع من الاخلاص لكن الايمان اشمل من
الاخلاص
الايمان هو التصديق الجازم الذي لا يتخلله
الشك
ويقتضي العمل
والظن هنا
المقصود به
اليقين
الظن هنا الذين يظنون انهم ملاق الله
هو المقصود به اليقين يعني يوقنون
بلقاء الله لكن استعمال الظن هنا له اسباب
لغويه لو فتحناها رحيني
الاخوه بيرموني من الشباك
differان
تصديق
الايمانش
ايش
يقتضي العمل طيبمان
ايمان
القران سنه
قول هو اعتقاد
بالجنان واعتقادعتقاد
بالجنان وقول باللسان
وعمل بالجوارح والاركان
يزيد بطاعه الرحمن وينقص
بطاعه الشيطان ايمان
[Silence]
rises
‏acced
another access point of you cannysically
rise toevel
[Silence]
ازداد
increesie
why
have
to
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا ما
ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا نساله تعالى
ان يزيدنا علما ونساله سبحانه ان يجعلنا
هداه مهديين والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد